[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
JEROME DOCHEZ: Good afternoon.
Welcome.
My name is Jerome
Dochez, and I'm
the build system lead at Google.
LEO SEI: Hi.
I'm Leo Sei.
I'm a product manager
on the Android team.
XAVIER DUCROHET: And
I'm Xavier Ducrohet.
I'm a lead for the
developer tools.
OK.
Let's start with what
we worked on last year.
So the very first thing
that we did was we've
been working on
namespaced resources.
Jerome and I actually
stood here last year.
And we talked a lot about
namespaced resources.
And sadly, it has
not shipped yet.
We have gotten a lot
of feedback from you.
And we're very happy for that.
Thank you.
And as we kept working on it,
we realized a couple of things.
The first one is we needed more
features from Gradle in order
to efficiently process ARs that
are not namespaced-enabled,
but you still want to consume
in a namespaced module.
So we've been working
with the Gradle team
very closely over the last year.
And we got that done, so
it's now available in Gradle.
The second thing
that we realized
is that Studio
needed a lot of work.
Studio has its own
understanding of resources.
It passes all your files
as you change them.
It builds its own index.
And that is used for code
completion, resource references
for navigation, as
well as rendering.
And so we needed to
update these to be
able to handle both
the namespaced projects
and non-namespaced projects.
And then you're all
aware of Project Marble.
In the last six months, we've
been working mostly on quality
and not on new features.
And so all of that
was put on hold.
And so as soon as
Marble is done,
then we'll keep working
on that, and we'll
be able to hopefully ship
namespaced resources soon.
In the meantime, we have
made some small improvements
to the resource
pipeline processing.
One of them, for example,
in library resources,
we directly generate the
R class as class files
rather than Java
code that needs to be
compiled in order to reduce the
strain on the Java compilation.
We have a few more
changes that have
been going in master
very recently that we'll
be shipping probably in 3.6.
JEROME DOCHEZ: All right.
Let's talk a little bit
about multi-threading
in the Android Gradle plug-in.
So for a few years,
we've encouraged users
to go modular because
some modules can
be built in parallel.
That's true because
all interactions
between some modules have
to be done through files.
So there's no side
effects, no side channels.
So it's really good.
Unfortunately, that's
not true when you're
talking about a single module.
So basically what
happens is that Gradle
has to run every single
task sequentially.
So obviously, we've
tried to optimize things
by using executive
services and trying
to shard the implementation
of some of our tasks.
But you know, it doesn't
really fix the entire issue.
And on top of that, we
have executive services.
Other plug-ins, they have
other executive services.
[INAUDIBLE] has its
own executive services.
So the result is that we tend
to overwhelm the build machines
when we run builds, so
that's really not good.
So to solve this problem,
we've worked with Gradle
on a new API, which
is called the workers.
The workers are
side effect free,
because you have to basically
cellulize all the input
parameters to every work item.
And it's going to be
de-cellulized when the work
item is going to execute.
So that means that if you
change the parameters after you
do the submission, the submittee
will never see those changes.
So there is no side effect.
Gradle can also
much better maintain
the number of threads being
used and the workload so
you sure that you're not going
to theoretically overwhelm
the machine anymore.
And on top of that,
it's relatively easy
to retrofit clusters
to use workers.
So we've been quite
busy doing this.
But let's look at
how this impacts
the build by using workers.
So here we've got
a single module.
It has three tasks,
A, and you've
got B and C, which depends on
A. So on top of these graphics,
it's what's happening today when
you don't use workers, right?
So you've got the
three tasks that
have to execute sequentially.
Now, when you use
a worker, you can
see that the task B
is spawning a worker,
as soon as the worker is
being spawned, because there's
no side effect
possible any longer,
Gradle is capable of electing
a new task for execution.
So here at Task C, you can start
executing on a different thread
as the worker for
B is completing.
So obviously, it's
very positive.
Because T2 in this particular
case is much before T1.
So now, if you do
more and more of this,
you can imagine
that now it is going
to be more and
more threads being
used throughout the build.
Unfortunately, you can end
up in a situation which
is not exactly what you wanted.
In particular, workers are
an implementation detail
of your task implementation.
So basically, that means
that there is no declaration.
Gradle does not
know if your task is
going to be using workers or if
it's not going to be workers.
So it cannot select your
task just because it seems
it's going to be faster.
So in this particular
case, it decided
to schedule Task C before
Task B. Nothing prevents it
from doing that.
And when that happened,
well, we fall back
into where we started, really.
Because the Task
C executed first,
because there's no other
possible parallelism
that can happen.
The Task B will have to wait
for Task C to be finished.
And then the workers
will be spawned.
But at that point, there's
nothing less, nothing else
to be run.
So basically, you end up in
exactly the same situation
as you started from.
So it's not that great, right?
So to fix this is basically
to switch all of your tasks
to use workers.
Because at that
point, if you go back
to Task B being generated
or executed first,
you can see that
the Task C being
scheduled as soon as the
worker for the Task B starts.
Because you have a
worker C, it really
does not impact the
overall build time.
But if Gradle decides that it
wants to schedule Task C first,
you can see now
that the Task B will
complete a lot earlier than
what we've seen before, right?
So this is very
brief description.
But basically, what is
important to realize
is that, if you have yourself
tasks that you wrote,
if you have yourself
a plug-in, you really,
really should
consider switching all
of your tasks to use workers.
We have converted 90% of
the Gradle plug-in tasks
to workers.
So that means we are ready
to play well with each other
and also with ourselves.
Because we've seen that
as we were switching
some of our tasks to
workers, we actually
accelerated over all real
time, especially for projects
that have a very few
number of modules,
or even like a single module.
So we can stop making
things small and parallel.
Its on by default in 3.5, so
you don't have to do anything
except if you use Kotlin.
If you use Kotlin,
and in particular,
if you use annotations
processors,
you need to turn it
on for KAPT to be
able to leverage the feature.
I suspect it is going to be
on by default pretty soon.
But so far, you have
to do it manually.
XAVIER DUCROHET: OK.
So one other thing
that we've worked a lot
is artifact transform.
So artifact transform-- our
way to process dependencies.
During configuration
of a project,
we don't have access to
the dependency graphs,
so we don't know how
many artifacts you're
going to be consuming
because it takes time
to resolve the dependencies.
And so we cannot create a per
task dependency task in case we
want to process dependencies to
do extract ARs, or predicting,
or things like that.
So this is a new API that
was introduced, actually,
a little while back that
we've been using since 3.0.
We worked very closely
with Gradle again.
And we've been using
that in 3.0 in order
to extract AR in a
more efficient way
than we used to do before.
Unfortunately, the API
was not enough to enable
us to do things like
predicting and desugaring.
And there's a couple
of reasons for that.
One of them, it did not to
allow incremental inputs.
It did not really
support caching.
And the other thing is that the
[INAUDIBLE] was not very good.
It used to run just before
the output of the transform
was needed, rather than
work as soon as the input
of the transform was ready.
So in terms of predicting,
that [INAUDIBLE]
is going to give us
a lot of benefits.
So we've been
starting to use that
for predicting and desugaring.
And I'm going to show
you a little bit what
that looks like.
So this is a Chrome
trace output.
Jerome will talk about this
output in a little bit.
And what we have
here is a project
with about 100 modules
running on a machine
with a lot of calls.
And every little
square is basically
a task happening in
one of the modules.
And so what you can see here,
without artifact transform,
is in order for us to
schedule predicting,
we're going to have to wait
until all the modules are ready
and have been built for
us to have a task that
consume all of those
outputs and then start
doing the predicting.
And in fact, we do it with
indexing of the main app.
And so you can see this
task here [INAUDIBLE],,
that's taking a lot
of time, and also
during a time where we can't
do that much processing.
Because it's very at the end
of the project in the app, when
all you're doing is
basically packaging,
and text merging, and
doing a few things.
So with transforms,
we can schedule that,
or Gradle schedule that
for us much earlier.
And as soon as a module
generates its [INAUDIBLE],,
it can schedule the
predicting library.
And it can be cached on its own.
So you have much more
caching granularity
because you don't cache
the whole task that
does all the predicting.
So just on this module,
on this project--
sorry-- with 100
modules, you can
see that a clean build
is improved by 15%
by this introduction.
Another thing that we've
been working on a lot
is lazy task configuration.
We've been working on
it for quite a while.
But we've basically made
everything lazy, well, mostly.
And we wanted to show you
the impact that it can have.
So on the left side, you
have the same exact module,
you know, 100 module projects.
And you can see that if you
run it without lazy task,
we configure almost
19,000 tasks.
That's a lot of
tasks to configure.
And on the right side
with the right flag on,
we only configure about
3,000, 2,400 of which
are actually needed
by the build.
And there's a little bit
under 800 actually created
[INAUDIBLE].
This is a bug that we need
to fix in our plug-in.
A few of them
actually are need it.
Some of them are not.
And when you look in
detail at the time,
you can see that configuration
goes from 1.8 seconds
to about one second.
But then you also have
some of that time lost back
in the graph calculation.
So what's happening
is that, as Gradle
build a task, graph of
all the tasks to execute,
it realized that, well, it
needs to configure those.
But overall, we are
still gaining about 25%
configuration time
on this project.
JEROME DOCHEZ: So another thing
that we talked about a lot
last year was incremental
and additional processing.
So again, with Gradle, we worked
on implementing and the ability
to have incremental
compilation even when
there is annotation
processors on the class pass.
This has been delivered.
So now we have the ability
to run incremental.
Obviously, this is dependent
on annotation processors
to play well.
And here we have a list
of the top 10 annotation
processors as we see being used
through our performance data.
And we've already
converted six of them,
and we're still working on
the four remaining ones.
We will continue monitoring this
list of most used annotation
processors, at least
open source ones.
And we will try to convert
them as much as we can.
But you have to
be careful, again,
that if you have your own
annotation processors,
it's very important that
you make the effort to make
it incremental capable.
Usually, it's not
very complicated.
One thing that we also
did as part of this work
is to make sure we blame
correctly the annotation
processors which
are being configured
and that are not incremental
capable so that if you are
a provider of an
annotation processor,
you will get-- start
in getting some,
you know, maybe angry
emails from your users that,
why is your annotation processor
not capable of handling
incremental compilation yet?
So if you see things
which are open source,
please talk to the author.
If you [INAUDIBLE]
which are in house,
you will have to fix
it yourself, obviously.
We also have a page on our
documentation that lists all
of the annotation processors
that were converted on this
list-- there are some other ones
which are not in the top 10--
the version at
which they started
being incremental capable.
And we also list the ones
in the plans that we have.
Feel free to send
us email if you want
us to add some stuff there.
But it's basically the reference
about what's available today.
And since we are at it, we
also added support for Kotlin,
obviously.
So now if you use Kotlin and
you have annotation processors,
we also have the ability to
run KAPT in incremental mode.
It's dependent, obviously, on
the same annotation processors
being incremental, but as
you can see on those graphs,
the numbers are
pretty impressive.
We are really continuing to
push forward incrementality
as being a very important
feature of the Kotlin plug-in.
XAVIER DUCROHET: OK.
So one other thing
that we did is
we tried to improve
the performance of sync
inside Studio.
A lot of the time spent when
you import a project is actually
spent in Gradle.
And so if you look at the
old thing that we had before,
the first thing that we need to
do is build that model, right?
We need to query Gradle in order
to know which module you have,
what are the
properties, and what's
the dependency between module
and external libraries?
And so we have to call Gradle,
which configure the projects.
Because we need dependencies.
We resolve the dependency.
And then we query that model.
The model query is
actually very quick.
And then, well, Android relies
a lot on generated source code,
right?
Your R class, AIDL,
[INAUDIBLE] script.
So we always call into another
build that configures again,
resolve dependency, and
then run some tests.
So we worked closely
again with Gradle
in order to contribute
some changes to the tooling
API of Gradle in order to be
able to do both in the same
build.
So now we can do only
one single configuration.
We can do one
dependency resolution.
Then we query the model.
And during the
query of the model,
as we query it and we process
it inside our plug-in,
we accumulate the
list of tasks that
represent generating sources,
and then we scatter them,
and then Gradle
will run them after.
We also did a change here.
Because Studio now is able to
create virtual classes for R,
right?
So as I mentioned
earlier, Studio
is passing your resource
file as you edit them.
And it always knows
what's going on.
And so it's creating
some virtual R classes
so that it doesn't have
to rely on the build.
So if you add a
string to your file,
you don't have to build in
order to update your R class.
It's just on virtually for you.
And so since we do that, we
don't have to build it anymore.
So as you're seeing
the post-sync build,
which is now integrated, it
just does not run that task.
And therefore, you have
a faster sync as well.
LEO SEI: So another
thing we launched,
as you may have heard,
is apply changes.
And this enables you
to make small edits
and deploy while keeping
your app in its state.
It's actually pretty
fast because it does not
restart the app.
But unlike Instant Run,
which some of you may know,
it does not modify the build.
Instead, it really finds
the classes on the fly
and use some new
runtime instrumentation
from the platform.
Because it depends on this
new runtime instrumentation,
it's only available for devices
running Android 8 and above.
It works best when you're
making really small changes
inside a class or making
small edit to our resources.
But as you may have
heard from Tour
earlier today, this project also
brought a lot of improvement
for every build.
We also looked at the
build output window
and tried to improve it.
We improved the UI and
also the underlying parser
to really make sure
that all of your
build errors show up as
a node in this window.
We extract the
relevant information
to make sure that you have
a file information, line
pointers, the
details on the error.
And we improved the UI a
little bit to expand the tree,
scroll, and select the
error node automatically.
This is a small
change, but we hope
it will make your life easier.
[APPLAUSE]
So as you can see, we've been--
yeah, go for build
output window.
So as you can see,
we've been pretty busy
adding a lot of new stuff
to the build system.
But I cannot talk about build
without mentioning build speed.
So let me deep dive
into this a bit,
because it's really one
of our top priorities.
First, let me set the stage.
To measure build
speed internally,
we use a set of benchmarks.
We use some open source project,
like Santa Tracker minSDK
15 and 28 for multi-dexing,
and another one
called Tachyomi and Signal.
But those are small-ish.
So we really wanted to
test on large projects.
So we generated two projects,
one with about 100 modules,
97 to be precise, and 50
of everything per module--
so 50 classes, 50
layouts, et cetera.
We also created an equivalent
project of the same size
but all squeezed
into one module.
And both of those projects
have 200 external dependencies.
And every time we make a
change to the build plug-in,
we run those projects
on various scenarios.
So let me walk you
through some of those.
One scenario is to
make a code change.
So we change a little bit of
code and rebuild the project.
On the open source
project, you can
see some improvement ranging
from 24% to 36% improvement,
between 3.1 and 3.5.
When we looked at the
two very large projects--
and here the legend is large.
100 is the one with
the 100 module,
and large one is the
one where everything
is squeezed into one module.
You can see that we improved
by between 50% and 80%.
In other words, here we
divided the build speed by two
on the large project
with a lot of modules
and by five on the
single module one.
The big improvement in 3.4
here is largely related
to the javac incrementality
that was added--
or that was improved.
All right.
Another scenario we ran is
making change to resources,
because that happens.
And so here again on
the open source project,
we can see improvement
ranging from 26% to 53%.
And in the large
project, we also
see good improvements
ranging in the 30-ish%.
So those are two important
scenarios, editing a source
code or editing resources.
There's others that we ran on.
And when you aggregate
the scenarios
that I just showed
you, we saw an average
build speed improvement
by 35% between 3.1 and 35.
All right.
So so far we're happy,
But-- but-- we also look
at real build speed.
That's the one that's
experienced by all of you.
And we do this by aggregating
data out of all of you
or the ones of you
that share with us
when you opt into sharing
usage statistics with us.
And so here's a shameless plug.
If you do not, please opt in.
It's aggregated and
it helps us a ton.
And it's in the system settings.
So when we aggregate
those data, we
see that the median
build speed increased
by 25% in the last year-ish.
Note, though, that
this is not really
showing the improvement from
3.4, which just went stable
a couple of weeks
ago, as well as 3.5,
which just went beta yesterday.
So now I show you
some graph going down,
some graph going up.
You may start wondering why.
Well, the reason is that, while
our benchmark projects are
pretty static, your real
projects are growing.
You're adding line of code.
You're adding feeders.
You're adding new
Gradle plug-in.
And this growth impacts
your build speed.
So if you're trying
to reconciliate
this graph's going down
and up, let me walk you
through a real life example.
Looking at Spotify, in
the last year and a half,
the project grew
by 25% when you're
looking at line of code and
230% when looking at modules.
That's about 3x the growth
in a year and a half.
It's huge.
At the same time, clean
builds slowed down by 38%.
So I'm going to normalize
using line of code growth.
And it's still a slow
down by 10% on build--
not great.
I admit it.
This shows some of
the current limits
that our pipeline have when
we're dealing with hundreds
and hundreds of
modules, especially
around resource pipeline.
But it's something
we're working on.
And note, also, here that
this is not showing anything
from 3.4 and 3.5.
But the clean build doesn't
necessarily represent
your day-to-day builds.
When you build
multiple times a day,
hopefully a lot of those
builds are incremental.
And so if you look again at
the Spotify change, the Spotify
project, the incremental build
actually got faster by 37%.
And if I normalize again on
the growth from line of code,
it was actually 2 times faster--
not too bad.
It actually shows that
making sure everything that
can be incremental actually
is is really important.
And as I've mentioned, when
we add cachability to the mix,
it's even better.
And so what you see here,
with a lot of improvement
we made to cachability
to the task,
the Spotify build cached
this time improved by 50%
while the project was growing.
So again, to normalize with
the gross of line of code,
that's about three times
faster if their project had not
grown in the same time.
So hopefully all
those graphs show you
that we are working
very hard to keep
improving build speed and
help you get more productive.
And the first and best tip
to get your build speed down
is to upgrade to the latest
Android Gradle plug-in version.
But we know we still
have a lot of work
to do, mainly around
configuration time, resource
processing, especially as I
mentioned on those projects
with lots and lots of
modules, and continue
to improve parallelism.
But that's not all.
We know that many of you
use additional custom Gradle
plug-in.
And we want to help there, too.
So for that, we're working
on a build speed attribution
tool in Android Studio.
The goal is to help you
understand which plug-in
and which task are actually
affecting your build speed most
and what you can do about it.
Because sometimes you're using
a plug-in that we don't write.
So we want to help you tell
the plug-in owner, if it's
you or someone else,
what's going wrong
and what they can do to help.
And this will be in
Android Studio very soon.
XAVIER DUCROHET: All right.
So we're going to talk about
some tips and some tools
about helping you better
configure your project.
So the first thing
I want to mention
is that configuration
should really be fast.
I talked to developers a lot,
with developers telling me
that the configuration
is fairly slow.
I actually talked to
a developer just today
telling me 150 module, almost
10 second configuration.
And this is really
not in line with what
the baseline should be.
All right.
So we wanted to
look at, how fast
should configuration should be?
So using the same
project, a project that's
about 100 modules,
and those modules
don't do a lot of
configuration, right?
There's only one plug-in,
the Android plugin.
And it mostly set up some
dependencies and nothing else.
So when we look at
configuration using build scans,
we see that the
configuration takes
about a second, which adds
up to about 10 milliseconds
per module.
Now, of course, the task graph
computation is there, too.
But depending on
what you're building,
you may not do all of it.
But here, for large, for
building the whole app,
we see about under two
second configuration.
So if you have 200 modules,
you should see four seconds.
If you're already seeing 5,
10 seconds, and you have 10,
20 modules, clearly
something's happening.
And it's actually hard
right now to figure out
exactly what's happening.
But be aware that
basically every code
that you put in your DSL,
all right, because it's code,
will add time.
And there isn't a whole lot
of way to make that faster.
The best way to do it is
just run a JVM profiler
and see exactly
what's happening.
You may be using
some plug-ins that
do things that they shouldn't
be doing, that are just slow.
And of course, I mean, there's
a few obvious candidates, right?
Don't resolve dependencies
during configuration.
Don't configure all
the tasks [? early. ?]
But really, the only
way to do that if you're
using a third party plug-in
is to profile it somehow.
So in terms of speed, to
increase your build speed,
we still recommend
doing several modules.
And Jerome talked a
lot about workers,
how you can get
parallelism for worker.
But he also showed that workers
have some limitation, right?
You have to spawn
them from your task.
And while you're doing that,
you can't run any other tasks.
And so you're always going
to get better parallelism
from multiple modules.
So you should still
try to go there.
In addition to that, we see
more and more developers
actually using caching,
distributed caching
or local caching.
And so imagine if you
have a few local changes.
And then you rebase your changes
on top of some changes coming
from upstream.
If you have a single module, if
you have some Java files that
have changed, you're going to
have to rerun the whole Java
compilation.
If you have 100
modules and you only
have a couple,
maybe three, four,
five modules that are
touched, all the other modules
are a good candidate to
actually get the output directly
from the cache.
So you have better
cache granularity
and more likely to get
faster builds from that.
And then the other aspect of
it is compilation avoidance.
None of the projects we
showed in your benchmarks
actually used
compilation avoidance.
But it is a very useful tool.
So I want to run
through a scenario that
explains a little bit what
compilation avoidance is.
Because we still
see some developer
not really understanding
what's going on.
So let's say you
have an app that
depends on Library 1 that
depends on Library 2 that
depends on Library 3.
And so we want to see the
impact of compilation avoidance
when Library 2 declares
its dependency on Library 3
one way or the other.
And so we're going to
look at it by looking
at a bunch of tasks--
compilation tasks, dexing--
whether they're using Java 7
or Java 8, it actually
has a difference--
and then packaging--
all of that when you do a
code change on Library 3.
So by default, of course, if
you do a change on Library 3,
Library 3 is going to
have to run its dexing,
whether its Java 7 or Java 8.
And then at the
end, you're going
to have to package everything.
And none of the library are
involved in the packaging.
So it's only affecting
that particular module.
So let's say you do a code
implementation change.
So you just go in
the Library 3 module
and you just change the
content of a method.
Gradle will do compilation
avoidance for you
automatically.
So it will detect that the
API Library 3 did not change,
and you will not recompile
either Library 2,
Library 1 obligation.
It works out of the box.
It doesn't really matter whether
you use API or implementation
for dependencies.
It just works.
Great.
That's kind of like, really,
your best case scenario.
Now, if you do a
change in Library 3
that adds a public method,
and I'm talking here
about adding it without
actually using it,
and you have declared Library
3 as an API of Library 2,
then you're going to
recompile everything.
So you're going
to run compilation
on Library 2,
Library 1, and app.
Of course, the output
is going to be the same.
So at least in the
case of Java 7,
you don't need to run dex again.
Because Gradle will look at
the input of dex and will say,
well, it's exactly the same
thing that I had before--
nothing to do.
However, for Java
8, that's different.
The desugaring process has
to look at the dependencies.
So when it process
Library 1, it has
to go and look at Library 2 and
Library 3, what their API is.
Is it using some language
feature that it did to desugar
and, therefore, it impact
the output of Library 1.
So you have to redo everything.
Now, if you change the
dependency from Library 2
to Library 3 using
implementation,
you save a little bit.
Basically, what
you're doing is you're
telling the consumer
of Library 2
that Library 3 is
hidden from them.
So app and Library 1 do
not see Library 3 at all.
So automatically, you don't run
the Java compilation on them.
However, right now we
still do predicting seeing
in the case of desugaring.
That is actually a [INAUDIBLE]
that we need to fix.
But once you do that,
then you will also not
run dexing, which is important.
Because, especially
in the case of Java 8,
when you use Java 8
language features,
we have to run it very often.
It's extremely hard to
try to reduce the cases
where you're not
doing predicting.
We are doing it very often,
as soon as an API change.
And here, I'm not
necessarily talking
about an API that matters to
app and Library 1 and Library 2,
right?
You could have a public class
with a public method that's
you only use internally
in Library 3.
And it's still going to go
and trigger a bunch of changes
in your consuming modules.
So compilation avoidance
is very useful.
Start using it.
It's going to get better
as we improve the plug-in.
And it's really going to
make your build faster.
Some caveats to
parallelization--
we see some developers
telling us, yeah,
I have 10, 20 modules.
And then they say,
well, I have one big app
module with 90% of my code.
That's not helping.
You should really make as
small modules as you can.
And then, as Leo
mentioned earlier,
our resource
pipeline is not very
efficient for machine module.
In fact, if you see
the chart that it
shows for resource change for
large module with one module
and with 100 module, the hundred
a little bit slower than one
module, that's not priority.
As we start working on in space
again on additional changes
to our resource pipeline, we'll
get much better performance
in between module builds.
JEROME DOCHEZ: All right.
So how can you understand
your build performance?
I mean, we all know that
the Android build system
is a very open environment.
You are not constrained.
You can have your own plug-ins.
You can have your own
annotation processors.
You can write code in
the build of the huddle.
So all these things
compound to each other.
And eventually, it's
very difficult for us
to deliver something
that we know
will perform well because you
can customize it to no end.
So you need tools to
be able to understand
how these things work.
And so you've got
already a few tools
that are provided by Gradle.
The Gradle scan is one of them.
It's very effective.
It will give you information
about why the tasks run,
what were the dependencies.
All these kinds of information
will be given to you.
One of the only
caveats that it has
is that it forces you to upload
some information to the Gradle
servers, so this information,
content, things like file pass,
file names, varient names,
and stuff like that.
So we understand that not
everyone wants to send this
to the external world.
So therefore, there
are some other tools.
The profiler is another
simpler tool that you can use.
It will still give
you information
about why your task ran
and all that kind of stuff.
It's not to be a visual.
But it is still interesting.
And is still something
you should consider using.
But to help you further,
we developed an ability
to have contrasts being
generated out of your builds.
So what we do now is that we
are capable of generating these.
And we can display very
visually all the tasks that
are being scheduled per thread.
So you can see here
on the left-hand side
are the thread numbers.
You can see the task here.
You've got, for instance,
the task in magenta,
which is the merged resources.
You can even see
the workers, which
are spawned for that
particular task executing.
And by the way, you
can see here visually
that, as soon as the task is
done spawning the workers,
the next task can start,
which is the process
application manifest in green.
So you can see how
here, very visually,
then your task can be
running in parallel,
even using a single module.
Because here there's
only one module.
On blue here,
you've got threads.
These are threads which are just
using the executive services.
So this gives you
a very good visual
again about how we
use the JVM resources.
You can even go a little deeper.
For instance, here you can
see that the task execution
span is this magenta color.
You can see that there
is the up-to-date check.
That's the time that
Gradle will spend
to figure out the files
which are out-of-date.
Then you've got the
task implementation,
which is the all phases.
So that's really the
code of the task itself.
And then we even--
further down, we
kind of split it even further
to get to different phases.
So that gives us a
lot of information
about how those tasks
are implemented.
So this is for all
tasks, obviously.
If you were to run this Chrome
trace with a different plug-in
or with your own tasks, you
would see your tasks as well,
but it will not be as
descriptive as this.
Nevertheless, it would be
still very interesting visually
to figure out where those
tasks belong and so on.
So now if you face yourself
with the impression
that your build is slow,
which I'm sure is 99% of you,
we would really recommend
that if you want to file a bug
or tell us that
the build is slow
and it should be improved,
that you provide us,
at the very least,
this contrast so
that we can visually look
into what's going on.
There is no PII information.
We don't have file names.
We don't have task name.
We don't have variant names.
There's nothing in there that
should be of any concern.
This is the same
data that we use.
That's the data that we
upload to our server.
So if you opted in to a server
that we took to the data
that Leo used to do all
these graphs earlier,
you don't share anything else.
So to have the trace
enabled, you just
need to add this property.
And then you will
find a JSON file
inside the build on the
[INAUDIBLE] profile.
That JSON file, you
can use it in Chrome.
You can load the Chrome
tracing facility in Chrome.
And then you can load that file.
And then you will see
exactly what I just displayed
in the previous slides.
Again, this is super
visual, very useful.
It taught us a few things when
we started looking at this,
even ourselves.
So I totally recommend that if
you have a very sophisticated
build, you try this.
Because you might get some
few surprises here and there.
And with that, I'd like to
thank you for coming today.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]